[Music]
foreign
since February 24 2022 when Russian
President Vladimir Putin announced a
special military operation the West has
walked a fine line in Ukraine
while it works to help Ukraine push back
the Russian invasion
Western countries are also carefully
calculating their aid to avoid getting
pulled into a direct conflict with a
nuclear-armed adversary
The Wall Street Journal examined Western
military aid over the first year of the
Russia Ukraine war
to see what's next
the war over the last year can be broken
into three phases
initially the ukrainians were looking
for almost anything I mean one thing
they requested early on which didn't
happen was that the U.S NATO impose a
no-fly zone over Ukrainian airspace that
was a red line the West didn't across
and still hasn't
but they were providing other gear I'd
say the first phase was a sort of
Insurgency phase and the anti-tank
weapons you know small arms and
essentially meant for you know what
likely to be partisan Warfare a few days
after the invasion Germany announced it
would send Ukraine anti-tank weapons and
Stinger missiles a stark difference from
its previous legislation Banning the
delivery of arms to conflict regions and
in March Germany also added 2 700
anti-aircraft missiles to that list
by the end of the month officials of the
Ukrainian Army were touting winds
Russian forces began pulling back from
Kiev and charnev by Wednesday April 6th
that withdrawal was complete
with a renewed Russian offensive in
eastern Ukraine the U.S had announced
another 800 million dollar package of
Aid in that package were M triple seven
howitzers
artillery pieces that can provide
long-range virus support from the rear
foreign
shifted to an attempted all-out assault
by Russian forces in the donbos area
Ukrainian officials stressed the urgent
need for even more sophisticated
long-range Weaponry the U.S responded
this time with Advanced rocket systems
like these that transitioned the war
into a new phase
[Music]
Ukraine also began securing this kind of
high Mobility artillery rocket systems
known as highmars and multiple launch
rocket systems similar to these or mlrs
as the war passed 100 days Russian
forces were consolidating their position
toward the south and east of the country
looking to expand their control to
strategic cities like this one the
arrival of these highmars helped
strengthen Keith's hand in these areas
but these types of new weapons came with
a clear Red Line attacking occupied
territory is one thing but we don't want
you using our artillery systems to
attack Targets in in Russia and that's
one reason why the U.S has been
reluctant in fact hasn't delivered
longer range artillery or longer range
ammunition that could be used in the
high Mars because it doesn't want the
ukrainians to be attacking Russia to
ensure this line and reduce the risk of
a wider war with Moscow the U.S secretly
modified the advanced heimar rocket
launchers it gave Ukraine the Pentagon
declined a comment on the modifications
which U.S officials said involved their
hardware and software
by the sixth month of war in Ukraine
momentum tilted against Russia's favor
shown clearly with this drone strike on
the headquarters of Russia's Black Sea
Fleet in Crimea still the U.S announced
another nearly 3 billion dollars for
Ukraine's defense the biggest U.S
weapons assistance package thus far
Ukraine made advances throughout the
fall first in kharkiv then in her son
Russian forces pulled back from kharkiv
in September
Ukraine said it had retaken about 3500
square miles of territory from Moscow
forces in the region this marks the
biggest setback for Russia since it
invaded Ukraine in February and in
November Russia ordered the withdrawal
of its troops from her son the only
Regional Ukrainian Capital it held
as winter set with cold weather and
shorter days both sides slowed down
their War efforts
but in 2023 A Renewed push for military
aid ramped up tanks like these kicked
off the most recent phase of military
aid
and marked a departure from previous
policies early on in the in the war the
thought of sending Western
battle tanks would be sort of regarded
as really being a very risky step and a
step too far now of course they're
they're about to go into the theater it
began with the UK agreeing first to send
Western Battle Tanks to Ukraine followed
by the U.S providing Abrams Tanks like
these and Germany outlining plans to
send leopard tanks like these ones the
Russians have amassed large numbers of
forces and pushed them into Ukraine
leading Western and Ukrainian analysts
to expect to further Russian offensive
because the Russians seem to be playing
for time you know it seems like they
want a a long War they're waiting for
something to turn up in their favor
while the tanks will increase the
ukrainian's combat power that equipment
is some ways off
and further constraints on Western Aid
Loom as the war carries on Western
supplies are not Limitless the ability
of Western industry to kind of produce
more equipment for their own armies to
replace the the equipment that's been
sent to Ukraine and also more for the
ukrainians themselves it isn't Limitless
the U.S has committed around 47 billion
dollars in military aid to Ukraine the
most of any country followed by the EU
and the United Kingdom
the extent to which this Aid can
continue at the rate it has been doing
recently is unknown at this point
and in a lengthy War
some Western backers of Ukraine worry
that time maybe on Russia's side I mean
it looks likely now that this is going
to be a long War the Russians are going
to end up as sort of you know suffering
long-term damage their military has been
been absolutely decimated the Ukraine is
of course have lost so much so neither
neither side looks like it's going to
come out of this War uh War ahead